tut on va parler d'un dernier sujet
parisien mais néanmoins peut-être
d'enseignement national depuis lundi
dernier un gymnase du 16e arrondissement
le gymnase jean bouin a été
réquisitionné par la mairie pour
accueillir des migrants
c'est une décision qui fait beaucoup de
bruit il ya une pétition qui a été
lancée il ya trois jours par les
associations sportives qui utilisent cet
équipement et qui se plaignent de cette
réquisition qui est prévu pour
accueillir 150 migrants pendant deux
mois renouvelable
il ya un homme qui défend tout à fait
cette mesure c'est ian brossât qui est
l'adjoint au maire communiste de paris
chargé du logement est en gros lui dis
ça se passe mal pourquoi parce que c'est
dans le 16e arrondissement est donc ce
sont les méchants riches égoïste j
ajoute quand même que lorsqu'on crée ce
type de places d'hébergement dans les
quartiers populaires on n'a pas les
mêmes réactions
donc c'est un peu de poids deux mesures
quand on ouvre un gymnase à la goutte
d'or personne ne dit rien quand on ouvre
un gymnase dans le 16e arrondissement
brusquement ça devient une catastrophe
internationale dont jolie vie on a
besoin de créer des places d'hébergement
supplémentaires et on a besoin qu'elles
soient équitablement répartis sur le
territoire n'y a pas de raison que
toutes ces places d'hébergement elles
soient systématiquement créés dans les
quartiers les plus populaires et réponse
quasiment immédiate de la maire du
xvième arrondissement de paris danièle
giazzi
il est inacceptable de nous montrer du
doigt comme ça je trouve que traiter les
migrants de la sorte en les mets part
quand il faut je vous invite à venir au
gymnase va 150 personnes et ce matin je
sais moi sur les fonds propres de la
maire du 16e qui avons ouvert la méduse
anime quand il y avait les plans grand
froid pour les gens qui tendent à nous
n'avons dans le 16ème à recevoir de
leçon d'humanité de solidarité de
personnes ses fans marchand voit bien là
encore il ya des gars des légitimités
qui s'affrontent il faut accueillir ces
gens mais il ya tout c'est par exemple
le garder
des élèves qui se prépare au bac des
épreuves sportives et qui peuvent plus
fréquentés les gymnases ou est ce
qu'elle est la bonne solution
d'abord c'est un sujet une question
extrêmement piégée enfin je me lance
tout de même là le caractère politicien
de cet affrontement est tellement
transparent tellement transparent qu'on
n'hésite à répondre sur le fond mais
allons-y nous sommes là pour parler du
faux donc la question est de savoir ce
que l'on propose comme hébergement à des
migrants dans ce fait très froid c'est
un devoir d'humanité
est ce que la grande question est ce que
la france fait ça prend sa part dans
l'accueil des migrants question qu'on
peut se poser
la réponse est pas forcément oui et
beaucoup de regroupement familial mais
les migrants finalement ya beaucoup de
demandes d'asile il ya peu de d'asile
qui sont qui sont accordés et quand on
prend les migrants qui arrivent aura
apporté à la population la france en
europe est assez mal placé
très très loin derrière l'allemagne
derrière l'autriche derrière des pays
comme ça donc voilà le vrai problème de
fond est ce que la france prend sa part
et ses histoires picrocholine entre le
16e et et l'hôtel de ville n'en parlons
pas nicole nous dit hidalgo qui
réquisitionne un gymnase sans demander
l'avis du maire d'arrondissement
je trouve ça fort c'est vrai guillaume
ebook à peut-être aussi un sujet quand
même démocratique est ce qu'il serait
légitime de demander par exemple aux
citoyens concernés s'ils sont d'accord
pour que un équipement dont ils ont un
usage soit réquisitionné alors les que
ce soit les par voie de sondage ou même
ou même électorale on voit quand même
que la population refuse ce chantage
aux migrants entre guillemets moi j'aime
pas trop ce terme de migrants parce que
derrière il ya vraiment du roman
familial de l'asile et de la migration
économique évidemment donc la population
ne rentre pas du tout là dedans
bah ça serait ça serait si on si on
avait six vraiment c'était un enjeu
humanitaire soit les gens qui seraient
victimes de génocides ou qui pourraient
subir un génocide chez eux il faudra pas
les laisser chez eux évidemment et puis
ceux qui luttent pour des valeurs
démocratiques et qui sont menacés de
torture de prison et d'élimination de
leur pays mais là c'est quelques
milliers de personnes par année
c'est pas ça dont on parle on parle de
déplacements de populations qui sont
qu'il cherche un meilleur niveau de vie
et et la population française est très
claire elle ne veut pas elle n'en veut
pas donc bien sûr quelque chose de
choquant sur les plans humanitaire dire
on préfère faire du basket ou alors le
notre petit le petit dernier il peut pas
faire ça ça compétition de basket vous
rendez compte et laisser les gens dormir
dans le froid mais enfin est-ce qu'on
peut laisser un seul sdf français dormir
dans la rue est réquisitionnée comme ça
des migrants ou si ça c'est une question
qui se pose la charité commence par soi
même et il faut surtout c'est le message
évangélique il faut s'occuper du
prochain comment celui qui dit qu'il
aime dieu qu'il ne voit pas et vous
connaissez la suite
donc à quelque chose à vendre il est
profondément tartuffe dans cette danse
est question des migrants il faut en
effet les accueillir correctement quand
ils sont là mais l'enfer est pavé de
bonnes intentions
en les accueillant on le sait sacré ça
crée un effet d'appel d'air et ceux qui
veulent les accueillir dignement ne
seront absolument pas compte qu'ils se
rendent en fait involontairement
complice des trafiquants qui mettent
leur vie en danger
la balise en battant restons sur les
propos de ian brossât je suis en
désaccord avec une analyse qui
consisterait à globaliser car sur le
principe
là je suis désolé de revenir à des
questions de principe l'accueil des
migrants
l'accueil humains des migrants là je
rejoins entièrement stéphane one more
time fait partie de l'habeas corpus de
la société française si vous retirez ça
il ya plus d'humanité donc sur le
principe
non mais attendez sur le principe il est
normal que dans une municipalité
on essaie que chaque quartier en quelque
sorte prenne sa part ça ça ne me choque
pas en revanche je pense que ian brossât
est impoli laissez moi finir en revanche
je pense qu'il ya en gros c est un
politicien et donc il a un discours de
stigmatisation du 16e arrondissement qui
a en fait des arrière pensées politiques
il s'agit il s'agit d'abord pour lui non
moins de soulager c'est la solitude et
la misère de ces migrants que
d'instrumentaliser le procès d'une
certaine droite municipale parce que
tous ces gens là pensent déjà à
l'échelon suivant c'est à dire le moment
vous faudra élire le baird enfin le
futur maire de paris donc évidemment ça
c'est malhonnête
comment dire c'est malhonnête c'est
malhonnête comme on peut l'être parfois
en politique donc c'est ça n'est pas
juste mais en revanche sur le principe
je pense qu'il ne faut pas céder sur
l'idée d'un accueil des migrants de
tendre la main à ce prochain que sont
aussi les migrants
et si chaque quartier doit y prendre sa
part moi personnellement ça me choque
pas en revanche j'aimerais que ça se
fasse une forme essentielle pour la
mairie et les élites et les maires de
quartier clairmarais le mot de la fin au
delà de la dimension éminemment
clochemerlesque du problème qu'il est
exposé à la fois par la maire du xvième
et par monsieur bon ça c'est que au delà
des principes il ya la réalité et la
réalité c'est que aujourd'hui vous avez
une opinion publique qui est extrêmement
fermes sur cette question des migrants
et emmanuel macron qui veut lutter
contre les populismes et il a compris
que cette question était un formidable
carburant pour tous les populismes
donc c'est pour ça que l'exemple de
l'allemagne et de l'autriche ne semble
pas un très bon exemple parce que
l'allemagne et l'autriche montre
justement qu'aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'on a eu des politiques migratoires
qu'il faut bien qualifier de 6 mais
laxiste en tout cas très accueillante
que le niveau du rhône le niveau des
partis populistes a pu appeler grimper
au niveau où il est aujourd'hui et pour
ceux nés pour ça qu'ils sont hostiles au
pouvoir en autriche entre autres merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre c'est la fin
d'un point de vue pour ce soir c'était
passionnant ce que c'est un point de vue
mais il est évidemment subjectif
merci de nous avoir suivis et vous
retrouvez demain à la même heure et au
même endroit
area mais l'élan barbon soir
[Musique]